did you know this something just blew my
mind before we start here
that uh freezies apparently are only
called freezies
in canada what you guys did that's
not true what are they called currently
in the states they call them
freeze pops and uh they also get called
uh
super dupers in uh australia or icy pole
i'm just looking at them freezie is a
snack name that's a cute
suck if i'm like hey give me a suck on
that icy pole
i don't know that's just way too literal
yeah suck on my icy pole you [ __ ]
come on australia be better it's these
insuperable cultural differences that
strain our relationships with our
friends down south
yeah dude what they call smarties are
what we call
rockets that's right that's so weird too
oh i would be so pissed if i wanted
smarties and i ended up with these
little
sugary pills yeah
rockets are disgusting so anyone who is
uh
not canadian i wonder if other countries
have it too no our smarties are like m
m's except the chocolate tastes
different inside it's like i think
brits also have our kinds of smarties
but yeah i don't know i just saw this
freezy thing someone tweeted and was
just like
important question like what are these
called and it was a picture of freezies
and then a bunch of people were saying
like freeze pops or like
other stuff and i was like what the [ __ ]
is going on here what's next they don't
have bagged milk down there
hey we don't we don't have bag milk on
the west coast
i really think it's a pretty useless
thing to be honest with you uh
but it's weird how many things are just
in philly canadian like i lived in
mexico
for a couple of years and what i
realized that was really disappointing
is it had no [ __ ] salt and vinegar
chips like i knew that ketchup chips
were kind of like a uniquely us thing
but like
salmon vinegar i thought was kind of a
and all worldwide too i think canada's
got all dressed but
american makes up for that with 10
million types of cereals and things like
that
salt vinegar is also like probably the
most english-speaking world like i would
imagine they
have that in britain and like the states
obviously has it too
well now we've established our identity
as
canadian identity our continuous
and connected identity and when you
define your identity in terms of the
products you consume
what's that called capitalist ideology
yeah
which is what i wish we were talking
about today
yeah this so so pills you love this one
eh this is like your favorite topic ever
or
freeze pops or identity oh let's roll
the music
[Applause]
[Music]
freezies are indeed identity although i
would be okay with ice poles or whatever
you said too
i see poles it's very literal it's very
analytic philosophy to describe it as an
icy pole
but we could ask the analytic
philosophers what truly is the nature of
language and how does it reference
icy polls or freezies
between a1 and a2 well hello listener if
you clicked on this episode expecting
some hot takes on initialisms
you fell out for the click bait identity
schmolotex
is that what you're going to call the
episode that's the name yeah we're
actually talking about identity that's
facts
but uh that's absolutely true it's a
1970s
take that matt made us read i don't
think matt's ever going to be allowed to
choose an article again
i'll see it's too early to say or we'll
just get you back
we'll just get him back by picking like
dare it as timpin or
just something uh completely to the
other side of the spectrum
next is detour to babel
[Laughter]
the reason that i chose this is um
generally speaking parfait is considered
or was considered up until 2017 when he
passed away one of the world's most
influential philosophers
particularly in the anglo-american
tradition and there's kind of two
strands to his work which have proven
influential one is his argument for what
he calls the triple theory
which is an attempt to kind of integrate
what he considers to be the three main
strands of moral thought together
consequentialism contractualism
uh and utilitarianism sorry uh and
actually let me just stop you right
there too and i should just be clear to
the listeners that right now what we
read was um
called personal identity by philosopher
derek parfit in philosophical review uh
in january of 1971 if you want to find
it online you can
read it before listening to the rest of
this podcast to follow along if you want
to
or don't read it or just don't because
you're going to have to do some ground
rules before
yeah there's gonna be a lot of the big
threads of moral thought and analytic
philosophy
but that i don't want to get into today
actually oh great well
this is why right that's this is one of
the things that profit is known for
right it's this three volume book on
what matters right
uh and you know also other things like
uh the repugnant conclusion which eric
and i might actually chat about since i
know his thoughts on it but long story
short the other thing that he's known
for
uh is his critique of the self or the
notion that there is a
thick or strong version of the self that
we can
talk about and this also has moral
implications since
private makes this really kind of
striking argument which is that
kind of drawing later in his life on
nietzsche actually saying that
if you go back and you look at many of
the moral arguments philosophers in the
european tradition have put forward
most of them are predicated on some
theory of what the self is
uh and that the self is that what
matters right
and we can talk about like the different
flavors of software that he kind of
diagnoses but
the argument he makes is that the self
actually doesn't really exist
right yeah european philosophy in this
respect is just a kind of misguided
effort
to talk about something that we had no
business talking about uh
consequently once you kind of withdraw
this notion of softwood from our moral
vocabulary
we can't really talk about morality in
the same way any longer because
it's not about interests or saving the
soul before we get to that before we get
to that we should take this we should
take this step by step i think because
there's some argumentative moves yeah so
the majority
of the audience will not have read this
and probably will not read it
so whatever you say about it we're gonna
have to go slow which is hard because
we've been arguing about this hardcore
in chat
for two days well have we been arguing
about it provide any necessary context
discussion
listeners i'm sorry also we have a no
jargon rule
usually i enforce that but i'm already
feeling myself getting
read around the ears because of how much
this article pissed me off
so we're going to use the talking stick
try to indicate when you have to make a
point but keep your points short because
otherwise we're going to be talking over
each other
i'm going to try but question of the day
do we have personal identities and if so
what are they consistent
how do we talk about it with language
and the thing is
funnily enough i agree with the
conclusion
generally so do i though not at all with
the method by which he reaches the
conclusion
and for that reason i am skeptical of
his conclusion because of the way he
reaches it and i don't know how much
we're going to deal with this today but
it is to say is identity as a concept
a sing or too singular to express
the vicitudes and variability of time
memory and can you all attribute that to
one thing called the self and then by
extension of course as matt was bringing
up
can you make a moral philosophy or a
political philosophy based on the self
his answer is we should be skeptical of
it because the self
is subject to time change visititudes of
life and all that
so it was tough to get through though
that's for [ __ ] [ __ ] it is tough to
get through and like i don't i mean that
was that was a good little run down
um but yeah i mean i guess another way
of putting it too is like it's delving
onto the question of like is there some
sort of a stable like
human like yeah i guess identity is
right but i mean it kept making me think
that this is like
kind of against the philosophy of
essences of human essences that it's
like everything
it's much more of a process like in some
ways he's pointing out almost like
a commonsensical thing that we have even
kind of talked about it's one of our
jokes
about 20 year olds being idiots right
and i think it's predicated on the fact
that you change so much
um you know that that's why it's like
embarrassing for me to think about how
much i loved uh
you know richard dawkins when i was 20
years old because there's something
intuitive about the fact that that
really doesn't feel like me
anymore like that when we do insult 20
year olds we're insulting ourselves
x amount of years ago but was it really
me like like
in what way was that myself so i think
that's like another way of sort of
setting up the question
yeah i was big into blink 282 when i was
14 years old so believe me i know
i thought take off your pants and jacket
i mean i mean the basic way that locke
sets it up is like if you remember it
then it's you and if you don't remember
it then it's not you
is that that is that fair that's
probably really simple but that's kind
of
yeah that's that's the view that par fit
is kind of going to like take on
like kind of disagree with and go in a
different direction with but basically
yeah i
i make fun of 20 year olds because i
still remember being one i
am good towards my students when i when
i
teach because i still remember having
gone through their
exact process and some of the [ __ ] that
i had to deal with and so i feel very
sympathetic
whereas it's hard to have sympathy with
people who
you've never been through their
situation or you can't remember it or
you don't have that
that sort of sympathetic psychological
connection
to their own situation so it becomes
harder
to like you know be nice to them or feel
bad for them or
something like that well here i'll just
i'm going to briefly kind of summarize
what he takes to be like the things that
he's targeting because it is the
lockheed
theory of software but it's more than
that right uh so just putting it really
briefly he says
if you go back through the history of
european philosophical thought
uh and there's a lot of implications
that quote from this we can talk about
later he says
there are kind of four candidates uh
that are plausible
for what the self happens to be you know
what makes you
you if you want to call it that right
and put it really briefly like
the answers are the soul is what makes
you you and that's really been very
popular in
greek philosophy christian philosophy
you could also call it islamic
philosophy as well
right the soul is what makes you you and
then the second kind of art
like candidate put forward is the body
the body is what makes you you
right so because i have this body you
know and there's a lot of connotations
to that
that's what makes me me right then the
third candidate uh which he thinks is
considerably more plausible
because he just doesn't think the soul
or the body theories really have a lot
of traction any longer for reasons we
can discuss
but the third candidate is the brain
right the brain is what makes me me
right so as long as i have the same
brain tomorrow that i do today
uh i'm still me right and there's some
interesting implications that we can
dive into with that like one of you
mentioned you know what about real world
cases well they're people who have had
for instance brain accidents
or have part of their brain removed
right and we'll claim people around them
will say well you're a different person
now
right um there's some interesting kind
of implications for that where you can
actually test this theory
but the fourth candidate which he thinks
is the strongest theory for reasons that
we can unpack
uh and he doesn't really talk about it
that much in this paper but it comes out
a lot more prominently in his book
reasons of persons
is like eric was saying the lockheed
theory of selfhood that it's
my memories of being someone yesterday
and then the year before and then the
year before
and the kind of psychological continuity
uh between who i was then and who i am
right now that makes me me
right uh so i am matt mcmanus because i
remember being matt mcmanus at age 10
and age one age two or
seven i don't remember i don't remember
being victor at age two but but by the
way
but i guess what i mean is there a point
in your life that you would remember
of course of course but i guess that
prevents you from making those silly
arguments
like uh you die when you wake up and
then you're reborn each morning or you
die when you go to bed
and then you're reborn each morning when
you wake up again psychological
continuity was
probably originally meant to take on
certain absurd conclusions
like that right yeah and there are more
sophisticated versions of this right i
mean one of the things that he points
out is that
obviously not everyone's a lock-in right
and thinks that we're tabula rausa and
that our experiences are who makes us
but he says if you think about something
like can't right and the canteen theory
of selfhood right
it's still experiential in a certain
sense in that
what determines who we think we are is a
kind of will that operates
in tandem
with a phenomenal world as it appears to
us right so it still has this kind of
experiential component to it uh
but he says you know what started to
emerge with modern philosophy
is the european philosophy is this
conviction that
maybe the reason why we can't pin down
what the self is
is because there just really is no self
right in a strong sense of the word
you know um it's kind of an illusion
that was created as it were by language
sometimes a very productive and useful
illusion but nonetheless an illusion
uh now perfect doesn't always go that
far but he certainly flirts with it in
reasons and persons where he says
actually
it's quite possible that the buddhists
might have had the right answer uh that
in fact one of our
obligations as moral agents is to
gradually do away with this vision of
the self
and to recognize that there's a
fundamental continuity between who i
think i am
and everyone else uh so i need to adopt
a more kind of holistic ontology
of the world than the kind of philosophy
of the subject that you see emphasized
in uh conventional european thought
i mean like intuitively that's correct
you clearly did some supplemental
reading because none of that was in the
article that we read today
so i wish i wish i had read the rest of
it but with this article today
the method by which he takes this on as
most analytic philosophy does
is by starting with an abstract af
thought experiment that you have limited
options out of a truth table and you can
pick which one you like best except he
goes through all the ones that he
doesn't like
gives you the reason why they're
untenable and then finally gets to his
point at the end
but his thought experiment is in our
weird parallel
reality that does not this one but his
uh counter factual reality
if you have a brain and you put your
brain into a new body
now no one would say he says no one
would say that you are a different
person that one's fine
however we can also cut your brain in
half
and put it into two different bodies now
we have a big question
are you is your identity continued once
your brain is replaced into a new body
is it both of those is it one of those
call them lefty and righty for which
lefty and righteous bodyguards
yeah yeah and it's also based on is it
neither of those
so you have three options to choose from
if you're talking about identity as
continuity
are you now is are you dead
and now exist in two places at once
because that would be
a restructuring of identity or
is it not an identity or is it yes
identity so he goes through the split
identity
yeah so he goes through these three
options and
gives a whole bunch of silly examples
like and i don't i don't actually mean
silly as in stupid here
other parts are stupid but silly is like
if you had
if you could split your own corpus
callosum in half
while you're writing a math exam and
then you could have each half of your
brain
write half of the math exam you'd be
done twice as fast and then you could
reunify your identity after
would that actually be identity so yeah
and you could watch your left hand
do the do the work that like you're not
actually doing if you're on the left on
the right half and like how weird
it's so it was it was bizarre and it's
but it is worth mentioning that like
and he mentions this in the article
right there's like some cases of people
who survive where like half their brain
was obliterated
um so it's like yes it's it's obviously
like a ridiculous example but it's not
it's not based on
nothing it's based on the fact that like
presumably you could survive without a
brain this is actually cool though okay
so it's not you
survive with half a brain in that
example because it used to be a cure for
epilepsy to actually
sever exactly the corpus callosum and
there's some funny stories i've heard
that we're not in here but
like people would be choosing an outfit
to wear that day who had their
their brains severed from one half to
the other
and they would pick an outfit with their
internal narrative saying i want to wear
this because i like it because it's blue
but then their other hand would pick a
different outfit
and put it on the one that they didn't
want to put on so it was like there's
two sides of their brain navigating for
captain of the ship
and one side wins out and the other side
wins out but it's not always the
conscious side that wins out
in these experiments but nevertheless
well here
i just wanted to kind of situate this in
context right because i
mentioned there are kind of four
candidates he gives for what with self
would be
to his mind in european philosophy right
there might be other candidates and some
people have argued that but those are
the four big ones he thinks
right uh and interestingly he never
really deals with the soul view
right he kind of just says nobody really
believes in souls in the sense that
plato does or
you know saint augustine did anymore so
we can kind of put that aside
and there's some people who might
criticize him for that you know if
you're a theologian but he says you know
the body view is sometimes popular but
inherently and he wrote another paper on
this right not very attractive since we
wouldn't want to say for instance
that if my hand was chopped off or my
legs were chopped off or even if i was
dismembered
that i disappeared right so you can take
away 50
of my body and in a certain sense we
might say i am still there
right and so the kind of stronger
version of a physicalist argument
right a kind of good scientific
materials argument is that okay so it's
not the body that makes you
you right or at least not most of your
body it's the brain
right and the kind of point of this
thought experiment is to act as a
heuristic
like going back to something like
plato's allegory of the cave right it's
a thought experiment to get you to think
about this
because he says well what about the
brain generates selfhood
right is it actually the brain that
generates this sense of selfhood uh and
you know he
gives a more refined version of this
thought experiment later on that doesn't
evolve cut it in the brain in half or he
says okay
imagine i were to clone your body and
then clone your brain
and this brain had all the same memories
uh as the other brain and i put it back
in the same body
and then these two figures wake up and
kind of go off on their own separate
businesses
right they have the same body and they
have the same brain but as soon as
one of them has a different experience
than the other
we start to like to say that there's
something distant distinct about them
that they're not the same person
right so this is where he says well
maybe it's the lockheed view that's more
attractive which is the conclusion that
he reaches in this paper
so it's not the brain that makes me who
i am since it is possible for someone to
have the same body
and the same brain as me and physically
indistinguishable in every respect but
not being me
it's the experiences that we have that
make us who we are
and later on he criticizes this view as
well right but i think it's a pretty
powerful argument as an intuition pump
if you want to call it that right
um because it does seem to me that even
if somebody had my body in my brain
if he goes out marries someone else you
know decides to become a [ __ ]
gamer you know youtube gamer rather than
you know critical theory podcaster
you know and he sits there talking about
world of warcraft or [ __ ] whatever
they're playing nowadays you know
all day long that he's a different
person than me
right i mean i think that's pretty
possible
yeah i mean it makes sense to me because
in our day and age too like you have all
these identities on
facebook and people who set themselves
up as these as these personal or
these uh public intellectuals and you
you're trying to figure out who somebody
is and we all talk about you know you're
not
the person that you sort of put out
online you're
you're something else your identity is
is somewhere else it's not there you
can't like represent it you can't
summarize it you can't make a list of
things
and so it like identity is always
obviously already a kind of
slippery concept but i'm i tried to look
for some stuff maybe maybe someone can
suggest if there's anything out there
because they're
parfit basically takes the opposite view
of i mean he starts with by
going against the opposite view of the
embodied mind theorists if you're into
like philosophy of mind
who already start with the assumption
that your mind is not confined
to your brain but it's actually
distributed throughout your
your brain your body and your
environment and all of the social and
and psychological connections that you
have with it
and so it's more of a the you could call
it distributed cognition you could call
it the embodied mind or the extended
mind theory
and i'm i'm interested if if these
people have ever
confronted or if there's been any
clashes between
parfait's starting point and like the
way that these people take
for a start well i had the same i had
the same like question too because as
someone who's like very influenced by
marilla ponte i obviously have
sympathies to like the embodied mind
but but i guess like the conclusion i
kind of came to was that they're not
really talking about the same question
because like i think like i don't think
identity and embodied mind are
necessarily the same thing i think they
i think the embodied mind
like it still runs into similar problems
i think matt kind of touched on them
before
with like you know if you take away
because i don't think identity is the
same as like a theory
of what the mind is like i think those
are two separate questions but i don't
know if
like i think yeah so i don't know if
they would actually necessarily have
anything in principle i mean
when i was reading the article obviously
i had a problem with the
thought experiment because of someone
who does like like is convinced by the
embodied mind theory i was like well
this idea that you could put a half a
brain into a different body like it's
ridiculous it's
it's incoherent with like everything
that i that i've learned from like
marilyn pontian phenomenology but but i
was like that doesn't really matter
because it's just a thought experiment
like like it's like the question is
broader about like how how do we change
like over time like how am i the same
person where can i locate
a self is different than i think a
theory of cognition
while we're on this i mean okay so his
identity
is basically means something like what
do you call i
when you say here's me versus the rest
of the world but
since you brought it up could you
explain how merlou ponte's
embodied phenomenology would differ from
this so he could at least
put that aside because as soon as he
started talking about cutting up brains
and putting them in bodies
that's every merly pontian's response
that was my response immediately
well okay but since i name-dropped it
merlou ponti french phenomenologist
quick summaries you can't just take a
brain out of its substrate and transfer
it wherever you want and think that its
habits
its reality its identity can just be
translated
one to one when it's moved because the
medium
the body is the thing that creates the
world and its meaning and how to
interpret and navigate it
anyway victor i wondered if you could
explain that position a little more i
think i mean i think that like the the
main response i mean
i could get into the weeds here but i'll
try hopefully i can come up with like a
concise
uh like explanation but i think the
basic idea like of an embodied
subjectivity is just that you can't like
that you you have to notice the way like
so much of our perception
and our in and our experience of the
world is actually like an emergent
property of our entire like embodied
engagement with the world and so much of
what we are
is a result of that embodied engagement
like just for one it like one kind of
simple example would be
you know like you you're looking at a
rock wall let's say you're like a rock
climber or not a rock climber this is an
example i think marilyponte uses
right and like how the world solicits
you
to it not because of like some cognitive
judgment that you're doing rational
judgment
because of the way your body as like
what marilyn ponte calls the body schema
has been attuned so like you know if
you're a rock climber that rock wall is
gonna solicit your engagement with it
it's gonna pull you in you're gonna see
opportunities
for engagement that have that are
directly related to how your body's been
attuned
as opposed to some mental rational
judgment where you're like i could put
my hand there
it's it's much less cognitive i guess
like our our entire subjectivity in the
world
then i think you know classical theories
that want to locate all of
cognition in the mind they kind of
forget the role that the body has
in in i guess what we are um
but then like to bring it back to
perfect i don't know like i don't i like
so he's making these these these claims
but if you moved one brain
into a different body like i think the
consequence of holding like a more
merlopontine view would be that that
just like isn't possible somehow because
like
the the it's it's like the entire
experience of cognition
like depends on the entire kind of
central nervous system in the body and
all of those things and like i guess
hype the idea would be that like you
couldn't just put a brain into another
body because
the whole system works as one thing i
think
what he would say is something like if
the brain even survived that
the experience of it would be so
traumatic
that it wouldn't be recognizable as the
same system so to think that
your you are in your brain and if you
just moved your brain
to a new body and this is uh hubert
dreyfus's argument against putting your
brain into a computer
if you put you just transfer your brain
into a computer
everything that you're used to about
being in the world
about experiencing like even a rock wall
as an object of climbing
if you had a different physical medium
that experience would be so traumatic
that if your brain didn't just die of
shock it would have
a serious long
rehabilitation to go through before that
could even be recognizable as a
functional brain again
yeah because i have a quick aside we
should read that article for a future
episode the dreyfus that would be a fun
one
and just before we get into the parfit
stuff again just to add on to that i
think if
we can all sort of readily agree that
identity is a fiction to some degree
it's something we build it's something
we construct it's something
of ourselves that we project into the
world and i think the difference here is
is sort of the material out of which
that is constructed
and if if it's some kind of uh full
holistic
not just brain but body and soul and
community and environmental relations
then that's the material out of which
you construct an
identity and so even if we can all
readily agree that identity is a fiction
the material
maybe is a little bit different we see
goes into identity and then the second
thing is parfit
considers identity is not important
which is another sort of contentious
point because people do invest a lot of
importance in their identity and his
argument is almost
i mean he lays this out right at the
beginning of the article so i'm not
really jumping ahead but he just really
says that if
if you think that all these important
moral value questions turn on what
is identity or that you have an identity
then you're wrong
you shouldn't consider identity to be
important in these
moral questions we can answer these
questions without getting into the
identity question because the identity
question as he shows through the use of
these teletransportation and brain
hemispherectomy examples
is an undecidable claim he says it's
just something
that we cannot decide and that's the
only
purpose that he uses these weird
examples for is to show that
you can't expect a clear answer about
who would be whom where would identity
exactly situation you can never
ever expect a clear answer to that so
let's set that aside and then get to the
moral questions and then we'll find that
even identity here
is not important for moral questions and
value questions
yeah and this is actually what i just
wanted to say because i do think
actually the phenomenological objection
is a good one
and it's something that he spent a fair
amount of time on uh so for instance
there have been some critics who
contended that he undervalues the
importance of the body
uh for a theory of selfhood and he gives
another kind of
less slow we say eccentric thought
experiment where he says well
imagine there was somebody who whose
frontal
cerebral cortex was essentially
non-functioning but most their brain was
still
operational was able to maintain their
fundamental bodily functions so they
were hooked up to a machine in a
hospital uh
you know most of their brain was active
it was keeping their body
going uh they're being fed through a
tube but it was very clear that the
cerebral cortex was never gonna function
again
even though ninety percent of the brain
was working working
we would still probably say that and the
body was still
intact that that person was gone right
that they were effectively
no longer there and what he kind of
pretends on this basis is that we need
to distinguish between
processes of cognition right or what the
brain does
and as victor would put it a theory of
identity right who i am my account of
selfhood right
and he says that one of the difficulties
that we find again in european
philosophy
is this notion of selfhood has been so
centralized that most people
aren't really even able to consider
processes of cognition
independent of some account of selfhood
right this is kind of the cartesian
ghost
that haunts us all right this notion
that whatever it is that i'm conscious
of
there has to be a me that's conscious
and there has to be a me that
is engaging in cognitive processes right
sorry and what i want to get at is again
uh it's not like he's trying to argue
that phenomenology
is wrong or its version of the self is
wrong uh what he's contending is that
there really is no version of the self
right that we really need to morally
emphasize uh and i'll get it very
briefly into his teletransportation
argument because that's
i think are also really interesting one
that i'm sure your pills will be really
pissed off about right
but he says you know think about it like
this you know the last candidate
standing
is this locking in theory of the self a
personal identity right that
i am my memories right that uh you can
put my brain into another person's body
but as long as i wake up remembering
that i am me i still am me
right uh and he says think about it like
this right imagine you know you're going
to a teletransporter
and your body is essentially cloned on
mars
and you wake up and you see on the
screen this other person with your
memories on mars
but then the person who's running the
teletransportation machine
says we're we're really sorry to tell
you this but your body is going to
dissolve right now
uh you're going to die and be destroyed
but don't worry you know you're still
alive
right you know there's this person with
your body with your brain and your
memories
carrying on on mars right uh
and prophet says that would probably not
be of a lot of comfort to me
as the original person because my body
brain and memories are still going to be
destroyed even though they live on in
this other person
it's kind of like the prestige the movie
the prestige yeah exactly right and he
says
this goes to show you that even the
lockheed memory theory of the self
is subject to this very serious problem
right because it doesn't even seem like
memories
give us a theory of the self the way
that we want to and there are people who
try to recover it or argue from you know
well
there are different ways of kind of
resuscitating it on this basis but the
conclusion he makes is that we should
just drop
the whole idea of softwood for the most
part entirely
and move on prioritizing different
things since it just leads to all kinds
of paradoxical situations
that can never be resolved right but
paradoxically when you say european
you're basically meaning the
intellectualist
tradition of europeans exactly not the
actual phenomenological
tradition that i mean i guess it would
be uh
questionable whether he encountered
heidegger or something like that it
doesn't
yes i don't think that i don't think
that any any i don't think that most
continental
theorists like that i can think of would
i feel like most would have uh the same
reaction that pills had
you know would be like well i agree with
the conclusion like like this is this
seems right like yeah that the self is
an illusion it's not
it doesn't have a stable kind of you
know like
kernel of like objective reality it's
kind of a fiction i think that most
uh continental metaphysics kind of
assumes that or even
or even psycho psychoanalysis does like
yeah psychoanalysis
example cybernetics does that it's an
anglo tradition
i would say that he would i think he
would say in fact i know he would say
because he talks about this in his other
three volume book right
uh that yes you know and in fact he
references haida granichi by saying that
the intuitive elements of this argument
although they put it less systematically
than
he did in his big book reasons as
persons but he says the interesting
thing about it is they never actually
draw out the moral implications
of what they're saying talking about
right i mean if you think about
nietzsche right
nietzsche says you know in a certain
sense our moral task is to become who we
are
right become who we truly are uh
heidegger says we have to live
authentically
right so even though they're critical of
certain aspects of the notion of
personal identity
they can't think of a moral way of
evaluating the world
without reintegrating some vision of
selfhood and prioritizing it
in their outlooks right and he says you
know this is really true if you look at
a lot of continental theory
which we've talked about before everyone
stresses in some way shape or form
emancipation
right and prophet would say if you
really don't believe in the self then
the only response to that is
emancipation for who
for what right there's no one left to be
emancipated so
we need to do away with all this
rhetoric just to
just to summarize a little bit where
we're at if you
appeal to something like the social
contract theory
of society then it's a society that's
made
it's an aggregate made of a bunch of
individuals autonomous individuals
each autonomous individual is thus going
to have
opinions and they're going to be seeking
their self-interest and they're going to
be trying to weigh in on politics
in the way that best serves them so this
whether or not there's an individual at
the center of this
matters quite a quite a lot so we have
this guy's version of it
which is essentially positivist in the
end it's like what do we what do we call
the thing that everybody thinks
is themselves and then we have i mean
we'll get to this at the end instead of
right now but there's a lot of
other explanations for this i i think i
mentioned uh
systems theory mentioned cybernetics
even even just the inter-subjectivity of
language i think speaks to
this being like it's not it's not just
what the eye thinks of itself
that creates itself there's a whole
bunch of interpellative
or intersubjective including language
itself is evidence of the fact that
these different individuals exist
but do we want to go through um a few
more of his
arguments about why that's not because
he he's he loves
the freaking thought experiments what if
you combined with another person
would your beliefs cancel out if if you
were a conservative
and i'm a liberal and we combined our
consciousnesses
would we just cancel out the beliefs and
have like a political
a politically indifferent person at the
end of it become a floating voter
if you if you're if you're one side
votes labor one side votes conservative
or something he also says i i don't like
gingers which i thought was weird to put
in yeah
so either elements of the two parts
would cancel each other out or some kind
of
middle ground like if one was stronger
than the other or some kind of like
middle ground would reach
would be reached if they're equally as
strong and
so if you like chocolate ice cream and
the other side that you're being
fused with likes vanilla ice cream you
might like chocolate swirl
after that if you could find some kind
of [ __ ] middle ground
product that'll that'll replace your
identity
god just like uh you know this this art
the reading this article like as a
as a trekkie like a star trek fan
especially of like the next generation
deep space nine like
there's a couple episodes that like
speak are exactly to this like there's a
there's a
sp there's an alien species called uh
the trill where they
have this like this like kind of like um
or i guess it's not parasitic uh
relationship it's more of a symbiosis
where they have a symbiant that like
gets passed from
humanoid which is more like a human to
human like up generations but the
symbiote lives like thousands of years
and it gets passed from person to person
and it
keeps all of the memories of all the
previous bodies that it was in
and then like and there's like an
episode where i think one of the
characters gets the symbiote
and then like her her like opinions
about stuff changes right like she stops
liking food starts liking other foods
because she's like taken in all these
other previous memories um so yeah i
mean there's a lot of kind of like
fodder
uh for like kind of stuff that's that's
explored in star trek well
actually this is why i'm a bit surprised
you didn't like these pills because
you know duluth likes science fiction
also for a reason right and this is one
of the things that
foregrounds right hold on hold on
just because person a prime and person
a1
reference science fiction thought
experiments
in philosophy does not mean that person
a prime and person a1
maintain the same cue preference for
fiction thought experiments to equal
state of affairs one in which philosophy
and science fiction experiments are both
the same thing
no no i know but i mean this is what i'm
getting at
the thing about it is that these kind of
heuristic devices that you see
developed in great science fiction are
really useful for thinking through these
problems in a concrete way
that's also digestible and
understandable to people so
i'll go back to the kind of argument he
makes about the tele transportation
argument right so
a lot of you i know we all kind of are
critical of this idea of possessive
individualism
right so it has its roots in lockheed
and philosophy
amongst others right if you follow c.p
mcpherson's idea right uh and you know
possessive individualism is essentially
the idea that what matters
uh is that i own myself and it's
important that i own myself because what
i want
are to have the kind of experiences uh
that are valuable to me in life
right um which means i want to
accumulate resources in order to have
the kind of experiences that i want in
life and so on and so forth
and importantly doesn't that mean you
own the products of your
of your labor of your body as well like
you own your body
and you own the products of the labor of
your body like lock talks about when you
join your labor
to something it becomes yours and this
is actually something that's shared by
lock and even
people like marx yeah exactly you you
own the labor of your body so it's not
like this is a weird
thing he's picking out a a strange
corner of philosophy it's quite exactly
why he points out that like sometimes
lock actually puts this
our locky ends like hi i put this in
almost bodily terms right that
my property is almost a part of me if
you think about you know
legal personhood right what i own and
who i am
can sometimes become very
indistinguishable right because they're
so
inextricably entwined in the philosophy
of possessive individualism right
and the teletransportation thought
experiment star trekkie as it is is
meant to show you look
even this idea that you are your
memories or your experiences that lock
foreground so importantly
doesn't really hold water right because
somebody can be there with your body
your brain your memories
and not be you fundamentally right
they're
on mars going off living your life with
all that but they're not who you are
well quickly can i just say there is
actually a star trek episode
where like a riker i know you're talking
deep space nine right there's a
transporter accident where he's like
he's like uh he's uh on some planet
and then he gets transported up and like
leaves and everything's fine but it
turns out there's like an
accident and a fluctuation and a copy of
riker stays on the planet and get ends
up being stuck there for like
20 years or they and then they find him
like or it's 15 years later
and then they both confront each other
and they're both very different people
and his ex-girlfriend is basically like
i like the long the younger version of
you better the one who well he's not
younger he's the same age
he's like but he's still like stuck in
the old past right because his career
didn't move on he's just been stuck on
this planet the whole time
yeah and i mean one of the things that
he says that i think is really
interesting
is it's not like he's saying papa was a
very humble guy in a lot of ways
that this is a really novel argument
right where he says
look you know there are various kinds of
european philosophers that have
anticipated this
nietzsche and heidegger amongst them
with the kind of anti-essentialist
account of the self
he also points out that this was put
forward a lot more forcefully in things
like buddhism right again
this idea that itself is illusion that
we need to overcome but he says the
problem with european philosophers is
they never are willing to accept the
moral
implications of what they're talking
about so you could even see him as
giving a kind of niching critique of
nietzsche
right uh where he says you know
nietzsche again argues that
the point of life is to become who i
truly am right
uh heidegger has to wrestle direct some
ideas helpful by talking about
authenticity
right many left-wing philosophers have
to argue about emancipation
for self-creation right and he says
these are still too beholden
to the philosophy of possessive
individualism and it shows you how
stringent a hold it has on our
imagination right that no european
philosopher
even those that critique the idea of the
self can think of
a way of thinking of imagining what's
important without the self or some kind
of self adjacent
concept right and in his later work he
says that's what i'm going to try to do
i'm going to try to come up with a kind
of moral theory
that is not really tied to selfhood
right at all
which as it turns out is a really
difficult thing to do
uh since of course then you have to ask
well who is it that's being moral and on
behalf of what
right uh which is the problem you spend
3000 pages unconvincingly trying to
answer
i should say very unconvincingly well
can i
but quickly can i can i just say like to
the to the point about uh
you know i think it's it's interesting
because it's making me think of our our
anarchy episode which uh eric wasn't
here for but the rest of us were and
like
chaos you know i think doesn't that that
that argument for anarchism of that
particular book kind of seemed to depend
on a very narrow definition of autonomy
that i think is maybe
somewhat comparable to this like very
narrow definition of cell food that
doesn't really make sense to me and like
i think that's
one of the problems that i had with the
anarchy book is like this
like this strict definition of autonomy
it's like what do we
it's kind of illusory and then it's like
you're making room for something when
really what matters i think is like our
social relations
and our cooperation with others and i
think to some extent there's something
analogous here where it's like really
what matters is not like some
strict stable identity that i can locate
but it's really like
the pro the life processes and like the
the kind of different
i think he calls it degrees right of
continuity degrees of connectedness
like all these things are really what
matters and i think that there's there's
something compelling about that for sure
and i just want to offer one kind of
olive branch to eric because i think you
might actually really like this because
one of the things that he says is
once you start to abandon really abandon
the philosophy of possessive
individualism right i realize that the
self
is not what matters and that the
disconnect i draw very sharply
as a european thinker between myself and
everyone else starts to become blurred
i realize that my obligations
stem far beyond uh just towards the
human
uh it extends towards things like future
generations right those who continue on
above me
it also extends to non-human animals
because the disconnect i draw between
myself
and human animals also starts to break
down uh there's some people have you
argued it even applies to the
environment right the notion that
myself should be prioritized over other
non-cognitive
cognate living things might be
problematic
right now he doesn't spell out all of
these implications in the book because i
mean i was already doing a lot
but he says you know this seems to at
least have an elective affinity with
what i'm saying
right that once we get rid of the self
as the locus of what matters there's all
kinds of interesting possibilities that
open up
uh one of the most obvious ones again
when he talks about future generations
is
if i'm not what matters purely and
exclusively why should i prioritize
myself over
somebody who might exist five six seven
eight nine ten generations
from now right which if you really think
about it has some pretty [ __ ]
weird implications right uh yeah if i
can
if i can take your olive branch and
stick it up my bum for a second
um i think that i do appreciate
some like some aspects of derrick
parfut's argument like
like my my little caricature of like we
are all rational individuals in a
marketplace of ideas making rational
decisions day and day
like that doesn't apply to him because
he doesn't think
that we are rational individuals because
for him you know
rationality is one of the basis
for sort of self-interest because you
think well if i'm me
and what's rational is that i have
self-interest in me
then i'm going to do things also for my
future self
because that will be me as well and so
what i should do now
should either be you know immediately
beneficial or beneficial to me somewhere
down the road
and in so far as my progeny also carries
on my sorts of projects in life then i
should also
and and it creates these like insular it
creates this insularity around this idea
of rational
egoism and he's trying to break that so
i do appreciate that
and the and the vista as this kind of
opens up well what if we're not just
connected with other human beings what
if there's
connectedness with other non-humans as
well and
environments and ecosystems so i mean i
mean i am i'm
pregnant with the possibilities but but
the way he just articulates all of this
in this
first paper which is really all i've
read of par fit
it there's just certain things that get
to me
i mean one one just simple analogy that
i
come up with is that you know he he
treats identity
like the the view that he's sort of
arguing against as really just like a
bunch of links
in a chain when maybe we should really
think of identity more as like
a twined rope with many many strands so
that it's not
simply as weak as the weakest link it's
more
like a bound fibrous thread that
stretches across
time and some of those connections can
be severed well
i mean i don't think that's a that's
actually an analogy that is completely
out of sorts he just doesn't think of it
but not here anyway but so i do
appreciate various
things that he says here i'm curious uh
i'm curious actually to you pills you
know like let maybe it's worth bringing
up
what is what do you find so
objectionable about the method
and is it and would you say that it's
purely an aesthetic
objection or do you think that there's
philosophical consequences that you are
opposed to that that follow from this
this kind of method
uh no it's a linguistic objection mainly
because when he says
we should do away with the concept of
the self and i
i appreciate matt making us all
charitable
to this because i think it's some of it
is silly i'll give you that like
the second i read stuff like this my
brain goes into like critique mode where
i'm looking at every line going [ __ ]
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] this with this
but i read the entire thing front to
back
gritting my teeth and i appreciate
what's being said here but what's really
being said when we should do away with
the concept of the self
is we should do away with the language
of the self
and the process of self identification
which
is only one very small aspect of the
self but this is what
logical positivism is about it's playing
language games
with thought experiments with words with
variables and making graphs and [ __ ]
like that
so we can we can say find that there's
some continuity with other thinkers that
we need to do away with the language of
the
of the self but when you're referring to
those other thinkers a lot of what they
say nietzsche included is
you do have self-interest but the
self-interest is not derived from
one single kernel self-interest is one
drive among many
that makes up sort of a chaotic mass
that comes to
be identified as the self and the
identification
is really important because whether or
not you think that self exists
it does at least as a work at least as
an identification
that people in basically every language
say i
as the subject of a sentence so it just
exists on that ground alone
now the question that's being asked here
is what does this self
refer to and he kind of
says it refers to nothing which i think
is really wrong because if you're doing
that
then all the insights of critical theory
that we usually talk about
on this show is that you don't just make
decisions
about yourself you're in a world of
systems
where other things make decisions about
you
too you're a criminal or you're like an
upstanding citizen or whatever or
or even identity politics more properly
when we're talking about like systems of
institutionalized racism or something
like that that's not you
deciding that i'm not a self or i am a
self that's something else that makes
a decision about you and we can talk
about state apparatuses and ideological
state apparatuses to so to say
let's get a rid of the language of the
self
i mean even if that were a valid goal
that we could just
decide in a philosophy paper and publish
it that everyone should stop saying the
word
it doesn't make the word go away and it
also elides
what the other interpretations of the
self is which
really do have uh large consequences
in every system that you interact with
because the world isn't the way that you
describe it using your logical language
the world is a whole bunch of power
systems
uh competition and different ways of
processing information
really all this is to say is that
just because the word doesn't refer to
the same thing through every one of your
thought experiments
doesn't mean it doesn't refer to
anything at all
if it makes me feel better i criticized
him for exactly this uh in my first book
making him a dignity central to
international law i'm basically saying
you know
there's really no critical account of
society in any of this it's a very
philosophical like big p philosophical
argument that
only an oxford philosopher could come up
with right since it's kind of
dissociated from the broader world and
like i completely agree that parts of
this are really kind of
very silly hyper intellectualized and
you kind of ask yourself like what's the
cash value in my normal life you know
what i mean how would i go about
criticizing
actually existing institutions of
repression and domination on this basis
but i do think in his later books i
don't want to get too much into this
because they're [ __ ] long
he does actually have an argument for
this right where he says look you know
part of the problem is that possessive
individualism like eric was saying
tends to lead us to think that the thing
that i should be doing essentially is
looking after me
and there's a theory of selfhood that's
built into this right which is that i'm
looking after me
now because i expect that in the future
future me is going to be better off and
i look forward to
making future me into somebody who's
wealthier more powerful etc etc
and this creates a kind of ideological
environment where people engage in
competition to try to improve their
situatedness or at best the situatedness
of
their next uh of kin right you know that
my children will carry on
my project of self-aggrandizement after
me right
and he says actually what we should be
doing is dropping this kind of
possessive individualist morality
whether it's nietzschean slash
continental
or liberal variants uh and focusing on
a kind of uh consequence i like yeah and
in so far as his theory is saying you
know like uh
like personal identity is not super
important for certain moral questions or
maybe all of them
like i think i agree with them in but
then i'm not going to
make that extra step and be like so this
is a good basis for utilitarianism right
because
because then you get into utilitarianism
and then it just turns into this strange
zero-sum game where it's like
you got to produce more happiness but if
you have more people who are less happy
their happiness could still add up to
more than less people
who are more happy so we should go with
the more people who are less happy
option like it just becomes this weird
like calculus of happiness and goodness
and it i think that puts a lot of people
off of this stuff because then
that just seems very managerial like
you're training a class of people
to go and like run a society based on
these views and that's a little bit
scary to me
but like i said i do like you know he's
not gonna also
take like the sort of neo-conservative
view that there is no such thing as
society it's just a collection of of
individual rational individuals so i
mean i'm
i'm on the fence which is okay because
i'm not on the other side of the fence
i'm straddling
so yeah what do you what do you do when
the cop says like put your hands up and
get
to get up against the wall and you're
like sorry officer i don't have a self
i'm not even here
i'm not even here you quickly saw off
your arm and be like see
i'm a different person now i i wasn't a
criminal
when i no my past self was a criminal
when i was in prison i am no longer
can i come out now it's funny isn't it
isn't there like uh isn't there a part
in like
isn't there a party nothingness where
jean-paul start like talks about like uh
his account is just like you you know
there are no does he talk about the
homosexual that there is no actual
homosexual there's only like homosexual
acts or something like that like each
each choice each decision you make or
something like that
well see that's like a perfect example
actually because sarah was talking in
the context of existentialism and what
you do
is primary but from foucault's history
of sexuality
there was no such thing as sexual
orientations until it was constructed as
a social category
so you have some sense among the greeks
where it's something that
some people do and then it becomes a
category of deviance
under the christian knowledge state and
then it's a psychiatric category and
today
it's a state sanctioned category right
so it's not like there's a kernel
of reality or gene that defines sexual
orientation
as identity but clearly it's real even
if it's contagious yeah exactly exactly
but i think uh you know but you raise an
interesting question before pills just
about like
so what is the you know with the cop
example right like
obviously these words are are like
playing some sort of a heuristic role
right so like if we accept parfit's
account which i think it's
convincing by and large so like you know
what is the divisive representation
that when i say the device of
representation i mean like the word the
self
like what is it representing uh if there
is no real self
you mean in that example yeah or just in
general like yeah in the example or like
in general like what's the what's the
like kind of um
implication he says right at the end
he gave me a trigger word no trigger
words the wrong word he gave me a word
that like
put me on to what my answer to this
would be if i were asked
because he says there is no underlying
person who we both
are referring to his past self and then
his current
self and then he says this is a decision
so decision for me references
systems theory and in systems theory it
depends
on which system at that moment whether
it's a
like a social system like a legal system
or whether it's a medical
system like the doctor is diagnosing you
it depends on where you are
in every single context what the self
constitutes
so if it's a cop arresting you the
context there
is whether or not you've done something
legal or illegal so then you're either
a criminal or an innocent person being
arrested
if you go to the doctor you're not a
full individual you're just a body
that's
probably broken and or needs to be
improved in some way
if you're going to court you're either i
don't know a plaintiff or a
or being charged with something you know
so it depends on where you are
in each intersubjective context how the
self
is located but i agree with him
only on the fact that there is not one
thing that goes through all those
events as the same thing except
as the person who describes themselves
as i so
that's valid but it is uh almost a
a floating signifier in the sense that
that saying i
doesn't actually refer to all those
instances
right so so there is subjectivity then
right as opposed to like so there's no
self but there is subjective
subjectivities
yes but subjectivity in the logical
sense is really
just almost grammatical like something
that can be a subject
of knowledge some subject which can be
conserved as something you can predicate
some other thing on like you have to
like obviously like a huge
submerged portion of parfit that we're
not bringing up here is
is in is in formal logic where he
actually draws these arguments out
and in like they're just basic logical
categories
in a if if a then b if b then c
so does that mean a is c as well like he
like this is all
that's almost like uh the the structure
of his argument is these logical
categories but i was gonna say
in terms of systems theory it would be
interested in how interesting how this
might cash out
because we've done episodes on like
autopoisos
a concept from systems theory about what
gives a system sort of its identity
across time
and if identified for the patreon yeah
patreon episodes
uh but if you are looking at systems
like what constitutes the identity of
the system how does it maintain
its identity across time and then at
what point do we say that it's a
different system
now almost again with parfit it's almost
like
i mean we're not talking about persons
now we're talking about any sort of
system
but it's the same sort of thing does
identity matter there even gives an
ident
a national identity example like the
nation considers itself continuous
right from its founding to the present
day but is it really the same
thing like that's at each pic 1950 and
1980 that's not really important for him
whether it's the same or not because
again we're getting into the identity
questions
yeah i should say he does have a very
very thin account of selfhood
uh where he basically says you know that
there's a kind of
continuity um that carries on uh that
isn't necessarily psychological
uh and might actually be invested in
other people
but this is the kind of way that we
describe the self using the language
that we use
but you know what i want to argue is
that there are ways that you can respond
to this but most of them tend to
actually
take certain parfidian objections on
board so
in analytical philosophy of mind there's
kind of two broad schools of thought
right
uh one is you know materialism if you
want to call it that
uh and the other is some iteration of
rational physicalism like
yeah physicalism right uh and you know
physicalism is usually associated with
people like dan dennan
right you know the argument that the
mind just is the brain the mind is what
the brain does per se
and then you have people like david
chalmers and then people like john
searle will say well no
consciousness is something that's
different than the brain it's kind of
over and above the brain
it needs a brain in order to emerge but
you can't necessarily reduce it just to
its physical properties okay
don't want to get into all that because
it's pretty complicated but the kind of
argument
that okay perfect influenced this is by
signifying that far too often in the
history of european thought
we've kind of drawn this one-to-one
relationship between consciousness and
selfhood
right that to be itself is just to be
conscious
right uh and what both the physicalists
and the rationalists if you want to call
them out have kind of taken on board is
this idea that
actually identity
is something that's not necessarily
distinct from consciousness but can't be
just drawn
uh or we can't be just conflated with
consciousness right that
the notion of the i that we're talking
about if we can speak about it at all
has to come from somewhere else
right then just the fact that we're
conscious uh and you know danette has
this interesting argument drawing upon
prophet saying that
it's kind of like a hologram that you
know plays uh as part of emergent
physical properties uh that we call the
mind
right this idea of the i is a virtual
thing
right and chalmers has a different kind
of argument in the same respect
but it's worth noting that none of them
are willing to go back to this old
argument
uh that you would associate with
something like intellectualism right
which is that consciousness equals
selfhood
and i think that really speaks to the
power of perfect's arguments right that
they were stringent enough that they
shifted the conversation
in a pretty interesting new direction so
there's like there's
two sorts of things underpinning
parfit's argument
against personal identity and why it
doesn't matter
and one of them is is what i'm looking
at the
i'm looking at some stuff on the the
rootleg encyclopedia
of philosophy here and so what we've
been discussing so far
with the fission fusion examples
separating brains putting brains
together whatever
is called the diachronic thesis over
time and then he and then he has
his argument from reductionism which is
another the second pillar and
reductionism
is basically saying that you can
describe
reality that refers to
bodies and you can refer to your
experiences you can talk in other words
you can talk about the world
without reference to persons
personal identity and and in that sense
it would be complete it would leave
nothing out of the description by not
referring to persons so
it's a reductive it almost sounds like a
physicalism here reality can be
completely described without
reference to persons so it's in you have
an impersonal
description argument underlying this
other sort of
this this sort of identity fission
argument that he presents
and the reductionist argument is i think
much much weaker for me anyway
but because i disagree with it um but
again i don't know if i disagree with
the idea that it can be
you can describe reality without
reference to persons without personal
identity
okay maybe i mean i'm not i don't have
anything ready against that sort of
way of thinking but it just seems to me
to lead to
kind of i don't know other other avenues
that i don't want to go maybe like a
sort of dawkins molecular biology where
we're just
vehicles for for genes and the ident the
whole identity and value questions are
in a completely different sphere they're
almost
like not important and then so when it's
not
important in that respect you got to
think okay well then where's the
humanism from this coming
because if if we accept this argument
and we say okay identity doesn't matter
then it's almost like an equation like
that plus that
equals we should be altruistic but
where's the force behind that
where where's the effective force behind
that argument
where it's really just more like a
mathematical calculation
supported by extremely brilliant and
subtle
and amazingly logical views that he's
presenting here
that's brilliant and subtle and i wish i
could could have written a paper like
this just as much as i wish i could
written songs i don't like very much
but it's it's a problem for me anyway
but i i think it's not just a problem
for you because this is ex
i mean you hit the nail on the head i
think with exactly the problem that he
devoted the rest of his life to
after uh reasons in persons not this
paper because he says
i've now shown you that the self doesn't
really exist in any strong sense
and that it's not what matters but so
much of our moral vocabulary
turns on some notion of softwood to give
it that kind of force
right and he says this is exactly why
people like nietzsche and heidegger
uh and bentham really struggled with
coming up with argument you know where
they would come up with arguments
against the self and the prioritization
of itself but they have to sneak it back
in
because otherwise they can't give an
account of what we should value what's
important
because value has to be valued to
someone right
uh and this is a point where he gets
into schedule right where citrix says
the ideally our ethics or our morals
would be completely impartial
right removed from any self-interest any
kind of personal motivation whatsoever
right uh but if you do that then
on what basis do you say people should
be moral since there's really no one
left to value anything
yeah i get that you know if we're
entirely impartial about the world
then if we're entirely impartial in our
approach to ethics why should we just be
entirely impartial or indifferent to the
whole notion of morality and
um citrix says this is the most profound
problem in moral theory
and he actually says i can't solve it
right it's just irresolvable we should
be impartial
not self-interested in our approach to
what's important but unless we are
self-interested we have no reason to
prioritize
doing something right and of course i i
completely agree that the way we talk
about things is really important and has
an effect on those things or the sort of
underlying assumptions of the way we
talk about things so even if we do
preserve language of the self
i mean we have to sort of shift the
basis in a certain way but again
like how do we actually do that is one
question but it really it goes to the
heart of all the political correctness
today because the way we talk about
things
does matter and whether you're a grumpy
person who just wants to talk about
things the way you want to talk about
them and that's it
then that's fine but i mean that's the
problem
and you're just running up against it is
that the way we talk about things
does matter
but this is a this is the again the
problem with the way that this argument
is spelled out like this because it's
assuming
that language is the type of thing that
can be
ontologically correct or ontologically
incorrect about things so if
even if the word self is a
a wrong word and doesn't refer to
something
then it doesn't actually make any
difference
because what he's doing by making this
whole
i mean like eric said you gotta have
respect for the guy because it's well
done
but still it's a game and the
assumptions that are
that it is based on is specifically that
language is not something that's used
by people in context for for different
reasons at different times
it's about a truth finding a
fact-finding
mission that we have to have the right
terms for things
yeah and i think richard rorty in his
own analytical way
tried to push in this direction i don't
know if he actually read parfait i can't
remember any references to parfait in
his work
but you know par yeah rorty says
something similar whereas like
the problem with parfitti type arguments
is they are subtle and nuanced and they
seem very
powerful when you push them to an
extreme
but they are dependent upon a kind of
analytical approach to language
uh that mistakes the fact that language
can do
many different things all right so maybe
when we're talking about the self
it's just a kind of language game that
we've played because it's the vocabulary
that we've inherited from the european
philosophical tradition
and it's useful for certain things you
know what i mean it's useful to make
certain kinds of claims and rorty says
you know maybe in the future we will
come up with a new kind of language
that's not dependent on
the self right and perfect will help us
figure it out
but this isn't something that the
philosophers can dictate to you from an
armchair
it's something that has to emerge
organically in our community
right and the fact that somebody who's
as smart as profit or schedule can't
really
think about a non-self-oriented approach
to
what's important uh just demonstrates
that our language hasn't shifted enough
in that direction yet we don't have the
vocabulary
to talk about a non-self-oriented
approach to value
back to hermeneutics yeah and
that's the way i would kind of respond
to this because i agree with what
everyone said here that i don't think
his own
i never really thought his own moral
theory was
basically fencing right and yeah and
it's because i think he never really
solves this problem
but i think it's because the problem is
really runs so deep
right uh that it's hard to see how it
could be solved without this kind of
transition in our moral vocabulary that
takes place
at a broader cultural level i love this
if i could just drop a quote in here
this is this is uh charles purse talking
about personal identity in 1892.
he says he says he says a strong light
has been thrown upon the subject of
personality
by recent observations of double and
multiple personality
the theory which at one time seemed
plausible that two persons in one body
corresponded to the two halves of the
brain will i take it now
universally be acknowledged to be
insufficient
but that which uh these cases make quite
manifest
is that personality is some kind of
coordination or connection of ideas
and he goes on that way in his law of
mind essay so
very much same sorts of ideas coming up
here in the pragmatist tradition
but purse is not a nominalist he
believes in the reality of general ideas
and he recovers
a sense of personality through
that path which i won't go into but i do
think that
when this language of selfhood does drop
away when and if
uh it's not that people won't be unique
anymore it's not like
we will regard people either as
extensions of ourselves
which is basically just roman slavery
and you're you're an extension of
someone but you won't regard everybody
as atomistic
individuals so you kind of have to knock
on the door of their consciousness
and say hey do you want to vote today
and then they have the choice of whether
or not to do that
and you could say that that's not okay
because you could say that that's okay
you don't have to participate
in the democratic institutions because
you're unique
i think that we wouldn't be in those
necessarily be in those sticky
situations if the language of
personal identity does sort of lose its
importance
but again like we said there will be a
lot of sort of back work to do
because marginalized identities and the
ways that people try to
move towards social justice by asserting
their own
identity is still a huge factor in loads
and loads of academic pursuits
and i think it's a little bit difficult
to get away from that i couldn't
i can see like a white guy from oxford
being like we have to get rid of
personal identity but i couldn't see
like a scholar from algeria or somebody
like that
saying it although i mean i i i couldn't
consider somebody like
i don't know like dairy does putting a
whole load of stock into personal
identity either for very different
reasons
but i don't know i'm just trying to be
nuanced here
doesn't um like isn't there a
distinction to be made though between um
like personal identity and this kind of
like trying to locate the the continuity
like the the the
it as sort of like having a a subject
independent
identity like this stable thing and just
like
something like uh like someone who ha
like the phenomenal field like the fact
that you have a phenomenal field as
a subjectivity as a as an embodied being
with a history
like i don't know like what's the
difference between i guess like
like are is that idea compatible right
because i don't think that the
implication of this view is that like
you know that yeah like a uh a
subjectivity doesn't have some history
which i guess
i thought of that because of eric you
were mentioning you know like
if you're a a racialized individual
right like the
the stuff that you go through like your
experience in the day-to-day world
is different right and it's just i don't
know i just want to flag that
uh you know just saying that there's no
personal identity doesn't mean that like
experience
disappears or something right i think
that's exactly what he would respond to
right i think he'd say
look we can drop the language of
personal identity and selfhood without
dropping the idea that again there are
conscious beings that have
experiences in the world right but we
just need to drop the idea is that
there's something called
i that has conscious experiences in the
world right
uh you can even make a kind of argument
for this having a kind of
phenomenological quality to this because
again he liked heidegger right by saying
that
heidegger's on the right step with this
anti-essentialist approach
uh to the concept of softwood that i
what i am if anything is what i do
rather than you know this cartesian
ghost in my mind right
he just doesn't think that he spells out
the implications fully enough that way
um yo do i do uh analytic philosophers
not take
wittgenstein seriously because i made a
when i was writing i kept writing his
name in the margins because i thought
that that was something that they would
be responding to but it doesn't seem
like he does he takes up any space in
her mind
he does i mean actually if you want to
know the honest truth
wickenstein had such a huge and
dominating impact on
analytical philosophy uh including
analytical philosophy of mind if you
think about gilbert ryles
uh the concept of mind and william van
arman quiet and his kind of approach to
these issues
also right uh that perfect kind of was
conceived
as kind of a fresh new voice precisely
because he didn't take that road
you know he didn't decide to draw on
wickenstein accounts of the social
subject and so on
uh he took this kind of weird sci-fi e
route instead
uh so at the time it was considered
pretty refreshing right uh
actually almost audacious that somebody
would do this without reference to that
um nowadays i agree with you that i
think he kind of went too far in the
other direction by
ignoring things like language and stuff
but
well i just mean in terms of his his
objection is that the word
selfhood or identity personal identity
doesn't actually
refer to something but it's clear that
it does
refer to different things a lot of the
time and he kind of
i mean his word what it was it
psychological continuity
does so much work in covering up
all the distinct ways that we use the
word sameness when it refers to
identity and this is kind of why i was
bringing up the the
systems theory approach before because
when you say i
it's it it doesn't mean the same thing
all the time it doesn't and it's
especially doesn't mean ah like
a declarative statement almost all the
time it's usually
an intentional statement or some
directionality
sometimes intention but not always he
seems to think it's like only intention
and intention based on memory but this
is
this is exactly argument ryle put
forward in the concept of mind
right which i actually i do think is
legit right and you can see
ryle i don't want to go too far with
this because uh i haven't really thought
about all that but ryle does something
similar to what parfit is doing
uh in using wickensteinium resources
rather than once perfect uses by saying
precisely what you're doing right that
look there's the specter of the
cartesian ghost that
is at the epicenter of many of our
accounts of the mind
and of selfhood and he says wickenstein
is essentially knowing why we can do
away with these
and instead of talking about there is
being something about some there being
some kind of eye
and trying to pin down what that means
we just talk about the kind of different
activities
uh that we deploy with the word i
if i make a speech act hey guys
i'm sucking on an icy pole it's not
making an ontological connection to all
of my past
selves well he does say you know like
when you
when you think about the idea i'll just
bring this and like of implanted or
fabricated memories
for instance and you do take the the
concept of identity
as seriously and central as the people
he's arguing against
sort of do then you might say that my
fabricated and false memories are also
part of me and then that opens the door
to all kinds of weird like reprogramming
people and [ __ ] kind of arguments but he
does say
that you know let's treat memory
as an idea and when you bring that idea
to your mind there's no mark or stamp
on that idea that says this is your
memory or this is a memory that i
experienced this is just a memory that
you have
and you infer that you experienced the
content of that memory whatever it's
showing you
but there's no from a logical point of
view
that i is not internal to the idea or
the memory
it's that's something you've added on
that's the extra part that's the
identity part that you got to get rid of
in a way and so this sort of services
his argument in a little way by saying
like okay so if your memories aren't
necessarily your memories they're just
memories of some past experience
then that's a basis for continuity i
mean if i have an intention to build
a hotel and but i die too young and my
children
take up that project and complete the
hotel there's a certain kind of value to
that
sense of continuity between generations
should we
should we start arguing about whether my
children are me well no that's
that's obviously silly right away but
there's a certain sense of continuity
it's not one to one because they have
all other kinds of desires and feelings
and maybe
apprehensions about the project but
there is a
degree there and that's what his point
is is
it's all about degrees we don't want to
treat identity
like it's a one-to-one relationship
there's you have
a degree of you know sameness with past
selves and a degree of sameness with
future cells and that's
that's as far as it should really go
that was my favorite part of this
argument actually was the
false memories because it yeah yeah
again like just to frame it for the
listeners he's
he's countering locke's
you are your memories by pointing out
that we have
false memories and this made me think of
uh like psychoanalysis
where you can have a false memory that
is
very formative to what you think of
yourself and what you how
the way that you react to other people
even if it never happened
um so yeah i like that part even think
about when you wake up after a dream how
much like
inference and connections your brain
sort of automatically does that by the
time you're describing your dream to the
analyst
like it's not the dream you had the
dream you had was probably some
fragmented crazy town thing like
like a lot of dreams are but what our
mind sort of automatically does
is it builds the connections it tries to
impose a narrative it tries to make some
kind of order
out of the memories and that part that
construction
that fiction if you will is then built
into it and you can't really tell the
difference between is this false is this
real was this my
experience or was this somebody else's
experience and freud kind of makes this
point too is that
you you you elaborate your dreams
and it's that that sort of elaboration
and the psychological connecting that's
going on there that's the
interesting part it doesn't matter that
you dreamed about
riding a flying unicorn naked over
toronto it doesn't matter
that that's the dream it matters on how
you sort of elaborate that dream and
make connections to other aspects of
your life
and that's why it's the talking cure
because it just gets people to
you know gets people thinking about
those things and so almost
psychoanalysis like
embraces the lack of of personal
identity
built into these kinds of things well
have any of you read the
the short story by fell okay dick we can
remember it for you wholesale
another one okay well it's the basis of
total recall you might remember you know
there's the arnold schwarzenegger movie
and then there's the crappier
oh yeah yeah you do recall but i mean
this is one of the reasons why he thinks
these sci-fi examples are good because
you know one of the things that
we can remember for you wholesale about
is philip k dick wrestling with exactly
this problem right which is
what if it was possible for us to
implant memories
in your brain uh so you remembered being
someone different in your past
than you actually were what does that
mean you would wake up after this
process and you would effectively be
someone different right you know you'd
have the same body
the same brain uh you know nothing had
changed in that respect
uh but your memories are different and
dick seems to say yeah you would be
right because you still beholden to this
kind of lock-in idea
right that your memories are what makes
yourself and prophet's
challenging that because he says look
modally
in a possible world if we could think of
something like teletransportation being
possible
i can show you how even this memory
theory of the self
can fall victim to extreme problems
right uh when we realize that somebody
can have your memories and still not be
you right so i think this is why some
people find analytical philosophy
a bit wacky when it comes to the thought
experiments because they'll say well
nobody would that would never actually
happen we're never gonna have
teletransportation
just like we're never going to have you
know philip k decks we can remember it
for you wholesale
but the point is to show that modally
since you can conceive of this occurring
in a possible world
we can't say that this has to be a
theory of selfhood that's constant
everywhere and in all places in all
times because it theoretically could be
if you want invalidated uh in these
kinds of scenarios that we can
think about right and i think that this
way of going about doing philosophy can
be
frustrating sometimes because yeah you
do think like wow that will never
actually happen
right um but i think in its best with
these kinds of like these kind of
parfitian heuristics or thought
experiments
uh does force you to kind of think about
the issue in a way those intuitions
there you go yes your pump your
intuition pumps yeah there you go
it's kind of interesting that he focuses
so much on uh
disproving the lock-in theory when
i mean you could also consider it like
just because you have
any amount of memories the second the
instant you're in a different
environment
you're going to have different memories
than your copy would
i thought that would like because from a
systems theory perspective again to
bring it back to
the thing that i know something about
anytime
that an environment disrupts or tries to
challenge your decision-making behavior
then you're a different system so it
would never be a question of if someone
has your memories are they you because
they wouldn't be
where you are so this would never even
occur as a problem
in even like a cybernetics context
i mean well say and i did i do just want
to say i'm happy that we had this
discussion i know pills wasn't too happy
about it
i'm feeling much better now matt since
we uh
starting off with freezies was a good
idea i don't know i just i like parfait
i mean i think that he has a lot of
crazy things to say and i'm never gonna
forgive him for
being that tedious over the three books
that i read but
these intuition pumps as victor put i
think are pretty pretty
compelling and they did kind of force me
to reevaluate
certain conceits that i had for instance
about the importance of self
selfhood in my own kind of moral outlook
yeah i mean the part of the self that
seems to
matter is the part that matters when
you're sitting alone
contemplating thinking about philosophy
which has
you know heidegger and and dreyfus
emphasizes that you're you're like most
of your life really is spent
in a state of like absorbed coping with
the world
and questions of identity again are not
really
coming up because you're not every time
you pick up a hammer you're not asking
me was this a sufficient
addition to my identity and then you put
it down you're like oh my god i lost the
hammer now
you don't think that way when you're
absorbed and coping and using tools and
getting about in the world so in a way
he's he's presenting a philosophy of
philosophical identity which matters
i guess you could say when you're
sitting alone thinking
contemplating writing philosophy but
maybe it doesn't matter quite so much
in the world because i think of a more
maybe cognitivist pragmatist
perspective would look at maybe the role
identity when you're
investigating some sort of issue when
something happens and you want to get to
the bottom of the matter you want to get
to the truth
you want to produce an adequate idea how
do you do that you go out
into the world and you experiment you
investigate
and you allow reality to then come into
your mind
because what reality does what reality
is is that which resists it's that which
puts
pushes back it's that which doesn't
allow us to just have
any idea about how things are it's
something that
stops us from simply making up all kinds
of crazy fictions
and so you might say there's no ultimate
reality to anybody's identity
but we're always against reality in some
sort of way when we're trying to
get about in the world and make our
ideas of ourselves when we think we are
one thing
something might happen and we might say
my god i wasn't the person that i
thought i was or something like that and
then reality comes into play
and it pushes back and i think a more
pragmatist or a more cognitivist
perspective would be maybe a little bit
healthy for parfit because he's too much
in the sort of logical atomist
conception where ideas are like these
atoms and particles that are
in minds whereas as per would say
you know just the same way that we say
we don't say
motions are in bodies we say bodies are
in motion the same thing we should say
we're not thoughts aren't
in humans humans are in thought i
completely agree with you right i say we
should wave the fire for talking to
pragmatism by saying that
look you know even if the idea of
selfhood is ultimately a lose your ear
it's so thin
that we can do away with it uh
nonetheless you know i think there are
certain useful things that we can do
with the language of selfhood uh amongst
others uh amongst others being
a critique of real abstractions right
which is something that marx talks a lot
about right
uh yes it's possible that things like
the self uh
whether talking about the private self
or corporate selfhood or whatever
might not exist um kind of cool hard
material reality
nonetheless because we treat them as
important they assume a kind of social
significance
and just to say like another sort of way
of looking at these sorts of
issues is that identity is not something
that's fully present
at all moments in time you're not all of
who you are in every single moment in a
sense you're
an unfolding journey of a bunch of ideas
in a way that you are sort of in as a as
in a sense and this is what like the
persian argument here again is that is
that if personality is a general idea
then all general ideas really are you
feel them in the moment in the living
present as self-consciousness and then
when you come to think about them they
become general ideas and like you said
those
those ideas have real effects on the
world and they're
unfolding identity is always incomplete
that's that's another maybe way to look
at it that parfit's assuming that we
have this
sense that identity is what it is
it's whole and it's always here and he
wants to say that let's get rid of that
but then maybe we can bring something
else in saying well maybe identity is
incomplete parts of your identity go
away part
new parts are added and it's more about
the connection of the ideas
then it is about like the abstraction of
it all into a single
sort of idea where you know i have my
birth my death and i am what takes place
between
well i wouldn't mind talking about
identity
not as not as just even you die when you
go to sleep
and you're born when you wake up but as
small as a moment is that's how often
you're born
and die yeah there we go there we go
peer process
pure becoming instant identity just add
water yeah
i often think about how uh you know when
i when i like have a family or kids or
something like that it's like
independent victor will be dead
but like but that's not necessarily a
bad thing new victor family victor a new
one will will emerge
from the ashes of the victor 2.0 of the
dead
of the dead independent victory and then
don't think of those future cells as
completely separate they're already
being determined by certain parts of
your present
you just maybe think of it as something
separate and
way far away yeah it's going to suffer
with liver damage
it's your fault tequila in the woods
all right well we survived a uh analytic
article
don't ever spring that on me again
please all right yeah i'll be the end of
that
i don't know we'll do more we'll do more
there you go victor [ __ ] breakfast
you guys uh are you guys ready to break
for some freezing break for some uh for
some icy pulls
frozen pops frozen pops here we come
uh this is pill part 36
peace woo thanks listeners
[Music]
you